there's an episode where there's a
comic-con and while two
attendees are fighting over
like a two thousand dollar tardis
replica one of them has his ears ripped
off
and has to have it sewn back on
is the episode called doctor huh
so tom i know you are a big fan of
grey's anatomy and i know you are a big
fan i mean to say you are not a fan at
all of grey's anatomy stop it man huge
fan of grey's anatomy yeah
i had it specially written on the back
of my driver's license that if anything
ever happens to me i want to go to
grey's anatomy hospital and no other
just definitely what it's called that's
the name of the hospital prove me wrong
it's impossible
who wants to sing the theme song right
now
brian i'm not doing it nina i know it
i'm not doing it you can't trick me into
singing on this show
i assume that's how it goes
yeah i love grey's anatomy
[Music]
it's hard to say brian isn't it i mean
with what 17 18 seasons i mean i i
couldn't pick just one but if i had to
i'd probably go with
episode 18 of season seven uh the song
beneath the song the musical episode oh
oh no why'd you bring that up i hate
that so much
what are you talking about right
go ahead this is a terrific episode no
it isn't
doctor one of the doctors whose name i
don't remember very well
she gets into a car accident it's deeply
implied that it happens because she's
singing at the time
there's a lot of dream sequence stuff
going on in the episode uh kelly torres
dr kelly torch she's the doctor right
all right sure so she uh gets into a car
accident and as a result she everybody
everybody sings
affordable but recognizable songs from
the podcast no actually it gets worse
they sing songs that were featured on
the show specifically
is that what's going on
yeah like is there yeah is there meaning
behind it because like it's literally
just songs they've played before it's
that
chasing cars how to save a life like
the hits from grey's anatomy
i actually like the show and now i look
like the most negative person about it i
hate this episode it's a badass
i thought that they were just playing
scrubs no because the scrub yeah well
that was the thing is scrubs hired like
you know robert lopez and kristen
anderson lopez to write dude the guy
people did avenue q to write the scrubs
musical which is why it's good and then
for this one they were like make tony
award winner sarah ramirez sing
covers of
songs by the fray
this is our whole idea
and the songs all seem like they're
either like
super on the nose like or unrelated yeah
they have an argument about how to
operate on somebody so they play how we
operate
which is
or like they're making fun of the trauma
victim because they do play chasing cars
after this woman gets into a horrendous
car accident and she's deleting it she's
singing about like i i i don't need
anyone as doctors or just like huddled
around her trying to save roulette so i
didn't particularly understand but that
wasn't actually my pick my pick was for
uh the next episode uh episode 145
of grey's anatomy which is called it's a
long way back because at the end of the
singing episode there's a scene where a
premature rubber baby gets pulled out of
somebody uh and you're not sure if it's
going to live or not i thought they were
going to bump it off i thought they were
going to be rubber baby buggy bumpers
but they didn't they
the baby survives
and then at the beginning of the next
episode you get to see it in in the nicu
and uh
i actually did bring a i brought a
a visual element i just want you guys to
check it out the most over the top part
of it for me the most overtop moment on
grey's anatomy was when they dressed up
this premature baby as captain cold from
the flash comics
[Laughter]
it's rubber
yes
they made it out of marzipan don't be
mad at me
it's not edible
i mean anyway
if you try hard enough thank you brian
try hard enough for the viewers not
paying attention brian just said it's
possible to eat that baby
uh i'm sorry so whose turn is it now
i'll go um so
grey's anatomy is a show that i've
watched a few times
with a woman i used to date many years
ago and as a result it always kind of
stuck in my mind as a show that i kind
of watch begrudgingly and just today you
know looking looking these moments up to
try to find something to talk about i
was struck by how entirely watchable it
actually is and i was like oh wow maybe
i should watch grey's anatomy again um
so i'll just throw that out there it's
it's pretty good it's well done um
so the the one i picked was an episode
called shiny happy people and it uh
guest stars demi lovato as a girl who
tries to claw her own eyes out because
her parents think that she is
schizophrenic
and as it turns out and i was hoping it
was going to be wackier than it was and
it wasn't it wasn't it was hardly wacky
at all there wasn't a zany punchline to
this no there wasn't i thought it was
going to be i thought it was going to be
a lot nuttier because as it turns out
she can hear she can hear her internal
organs
and that's what's making her her
go and they're all and they're all
telling her to kill gerald ford
[Laughter]
if you don't mind me asking and i'm
sorry to interrupt brian what was your
idea for like a a wacky
ending to this episode like it was gonna
be wacky i thought it was gonna be a
really i thought it was gonna be really
real over the top i thought it was gonna
be really over acted i thought it was
gonna be like extremely melodramatic i
thought that they were going to kind of
biff the diagnosis and i looked it up
and it's like a totally real diagnosis
oh it is called yeah superior canal
dehezen syndrome i think because i like
i always get the sense that while they
probably do say the names of actual
conditions on grey's anatomy i have
never once thought that like
people actually show up in the er with a
pull between two of them holding them
together that often
so i'm like when i saw that episode i
was like okay maybe someone has that but
it's probably not presented in this way
right where they're like i'm clawing my
face off yeah i looked it up and i was
like they got to be making this up but
it's yeah i'll say this the the show
exaggerates the symptoms apparently
because um apparently you know this this
woman played by demi lovato uh everyone
thinks that she's mentally ill because
she's hearing things and she
everything's too loud nothing makes
sense and then at the end dr alex uh is
just like she can hear her internal
organs and right you know i read that
and i was like well that's gotta be
crazy and then i looked it up and
apparently you can hear the internal
sounds you can hear very loudly because
of a thin a thinning or a hole in your
in a membrane in your ear it sounds
awful and but one of the things that you
apparently is true is that you can hear
your eyeballs moving
if you have this condition
that was like all right good restraint
grey's anatomy you took this absolutely
terrifying thing and made it actually
seem realistic right wow so the only
thing for me that struck me as quite
over the top in this particular episode
were two things one a bunch of doctors
sitting around watching this poor woman
get a cat scan and they're like i think
she's just crazy i don't know and
they're like yeah she's crazy and then
dr alex is like i know crazy i dated
crazy my dad was crazy she's not crazy
and i'm just kind of like you're all
doctors you're throwing the word crazy
around very liberally yeah it's okay for
me an uneducated youtube guy to say it
casually when referring to an episode of
television i would not call them all
good dogs medical doctors they're not
all good doctors yeah so the other thing
i noticed when i looked it up the the
main doctor who said crazy a lot of
times as a character named um this was
the nuttiest thing for me dr arizona
robbins yeah that's not a real name uh
she is played by jessica capshaw whose
mother kate capshaw is spielberg's wife
and
was in indiana jones yeah that's right
that's her daughter child of willie yeah
really
yeah it all it all comes together
full circle is that why they named her
arizona because like
god i hope so there's a really
convenient explanation but now it better
be
now i like it because you don't name
someone arizona okay all right you know
what i take it all back best show
nothing i have nothing
all right so anyway nina
you know about grey's anatomy you just
watched grey's anatomy
a lot of
the most over the top moment from grey's
anatomy that you would like to share
with us today there's so many good ones
um i mean i mentioned the people stuck
on the pole we've talked previously
about bomb the body cavity
there is a whole subplot where uh
katherine heigl in order to get jeffrey
dean morgan a new heart cuts his lvad
wire and basically leaves him hanging on
the precipice of death so he can get a
heart transplant and then they just let
her work at the hospital anyway
feels like maybe you should go to prison
for that but what do what do i know um
there's a kid who gets encased in
concrete because he's trying to impress
a girl uh there's
so there he's stuck in concrete yeah
yeah we've all we've all definitely
lived through that
in catherine heigl's defense jeffrey
dean morgan did come back to life as a
ghost and then he did and that's i would
say that also ranks among craziest
moments um there's the mass shooting
episode which i actually maintain is
like
and it's it's that highest ranked on
imdb for a reason i do think it is the
best two part of the show but it's also
uh
really i mean it's also like the shooter
is played by like the friendly um
secret service agent from west wing
agent butterfield so you're just like no
i trusted you you protected the
president there's an episode where
there's a uh comic con and while two
attendees are fighting over
like a two thousand dollar tardis
replica one of them has his ears ripped
off
and has to have it sewn back on
is the episode called doctor
huh gonna say doctor what
doctor what um there's an episode where
a guy saws his foot off because it's
hurting and he just wants it to be off
um
there's a an episode where a lion
that's literally my favorite john woo
movie
there's uh an episode where yeah a woman
has a pet lion and it roams around
seattle mauling people including her
boyfriend
none of these are your pick for most
over the top by the way
you haven't gotten to your picture
no i mean the the one that so it's kind
of for me it's like a little bit of a
like i think over the top like
it probably had to be the lion
where is the top
unless you're going to beat lyle
crocodile but like the r-rated because
that's what this sounds like it is like
okay what's what's better than lion in
seattle well this is a this is a
personal choice because it was just such
a good twist so at the end of season one
like ellen pompeo's character meredith
has been dating patrick dempsey's
character
derek for the entire season and like
aside from the fact that he's her boss
and it's a massive hr violation like
it's going pretty well
and
they're in the lobby of the hospital and
this like beautiful glamorous woman
walks in and she's like oh i'm addison
shepard you must be the woman sleeping
with my husband and then the season ends
whoa
so he's been married the whole time
wow what a cliffhanger including like
the audience also does not know but it's
it's perfect melodrama it's super over
like who also like that's how she opens
the conversation it's ridiculous i love
every second of it what if she had been
wrong
what if it was what if that had been
like a nurse giving him some files or
some paperwork or something right what
if right after that she gets mauled by a
lion
how many people did she approach before
she got to meredith gray it's oh hello
yeah
no i mean this is
something i appreciate about greece
anatomy is it knows exactly what kind of
show it is um yeah it's ridiculous
heightened camp and i love it
i mean
is the line more over the top
objectively yes is the addison shepard
entrance an all-time high of the show
also yes so my answer was he like
contemplated or something does it matter
basically yeah like she had she had
cheated on him with his best friend and
he just kind of like where she started
um she started it yeah she started it
this is the mature difference
in divorce course yeah your honor she
started it yeah yeah
yeah
i love this i love this weird dumb show
oh it makes sense yeah shonda rhimes if
you're watching this i am the sole
defender of this show please ignore
these other two i think it's fine i
think it's fine i'll probably watch it
someday yeah i respect brian
yeah
it seems good
seems like a good show um
not everything is for you and i know as
a white dude that must be baffling but
not everything is here it's hard i've
never had to put up with this before
thanks for watching please hit like and
subscribe so you don't miss a single
episode
[Music]